- Ah.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
So, okay, I'm very
excited for you personally
because I remember the
first time we Zoomed.
You were actually at your house
in Hawaii, I think.
- That's right, yeah.
- And I was like, "Why do
I not live where you live?"
And then also there was
art in the background.
We had this whole conversation
about how you love painting,
and I had no idea about
this background of yours.
And now this is your
first like ever, right,
like solo like art exhibition?
- This is it.
This is it.
- You're so crazy good, man.
- May 13th, thank you, Kelly.
Yes, one tries to be, at least
to be an unexpected surprise.
- It's incredible.
"So Many Dreams," I know
that's the name of it, right?
- That's right, yeah.
- That is one of my favorites.
I love this storytelling behind it too
'cause I watched this whole video
about you describing like your roots
and like, you know, why you paint
and the stories behind them.
It's really beautiful.
- Yeah, it's just, you know,
I've been an enthusiastic
painter all my life,
as a friend of mine says,
and this is my first exhibition.
I've had this body of work.
It's a retrospective.
- Yeah.
- Starting in 1987, really.
And I dropped into LA in 1982.
I came here, I got a job, I
got lucky, "Remington Steele."
- Yeah.
- And I stayed.
And, you know, I could afford paints
and brushes even though I'd never painted,
but I loved drawing.
I bought all these art supplies,
and they all went into a cupboard.
- I heard you say this in your video,
and I was like that's so
everyone though, right?
It's like you work hard to make the money
to be able to afford the things
you love and you wanna do,
but then you don't have the time
because you're working so hard
to do it.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, that stinks 'cause
it goes in the closet.
How long was it in the closet
until you pulled it back out?
- (chuckles) It was there until '87.
And my wife Cassie, God bless her,
she got sick with ovarian cancer,
and then one dark night
with just this kind of head
and a heart full of pain and fear,
I just got all these paints
out and I started painting,
and those paintings start the show,
and there's some kind of
articulation, I think,
in some progression of the work.
And they've all been in storage,
and I thought I have to let them go.
I mean, if not now, when?
Otherwise, they're just gonna sit there.
- It's such a cool way
to share with everybody,
to connect with everybody
because I forgot that I used to draw.
I just forgot.
And then I literally found
myself doing something
that I had to kind of pay attention to
and I was having a hard time,
and then all of a sudden
I've doodled this whole thing
by the end of this thing.
And I was like, oh, I forgot I even drew,
but I was doing it as like
almost a therapeutic way.
Do you do it a lot for that?
- It is definitely therapy for me.
It kind of-
- Because I heard your wife gardens.
- My darling Keely, she gardens, yes.
- And you paint
I love this therapy, yeah.
- I paint, yeah, so...
And we have this little
homestead out there in Kauai.
So that's the heartbeat
of our life really.
I think we live in a time,
which has been very...
The thump of anxiety in our
lives in these days is constant,
and I follow a lot of
artists on Instagram.
And so many people now,
whether they're weaving
or they're linocutting or painting,
you know, it's necessary
to have art in your life I think.
- 100%.
- Creative life.
I would not have made
it the last three years
without being able to write music.
Like that's my outlet, right.
And I actually heard that
you wanted to do album covers
was like a big thing for
you whenever you started.
- Well, yes, I mean, I left
school at 16 with nothing
but a cardboard folder of
drawings and paintings.
That was my qualification.
I got a job in Putney, South
London, and it was '69,
so the music, the world of Carlos Santana
was great albums covers,
and that was my dream
to make album covers.
It didn't happen, but my
son, who's a musician,
he asked me to do his album cover, so...
- [Kelly] I know I was
gonna bring that up.
How full circle and also
such a beautiful thing
for you to do with your kid.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, thank you.
- Like I have kids, and I can only imagine
like my kid would ask me
to be a part of something,
you know, 'cause sometimes
we're not cool. (laughs)
- Sometimes we're not cool, yeah,
and it takes a long time to be cool
and then uncool at the same time.
But anyway, yeah, that's-
- What a great time for
that, that happened.
- It is.
A lot of these paintings come
from a certain kind of
therapeutic anxiety,
nourishment of the soul, and I love it.
- That's important, yeah.
- That's where you begin with
you love the song, the
poem that you've written.
It starts in your heart,
the painting that you make,
and then you give it away.
- Absolutely.
(audience cheer)
So Pierce is not only
a great actor, but he's an amazing artist.
His first ever solo art exhibition
called "So Many Dreams,"
which is the coolest title ever,
starts Sunday, May 13th at 434
North La Brea in Los Angeles.
While we've all lived many
lives, especially actors,
probably not as many as you, man,
and because we are always evolving,
we're never quite the
same person we used to be.
It is time to find out who
Pierce Brosnan used to be, y'all.
As we look back through
past snapshots of his life,
I'm very excited about this title.
This is Pierced by Pierce.
♪ Pierce by Pierce ♪
- Okay, Jessi.
(audience applauds)
Anyways, so I'm gonna hit this button
and a certain Pierce from the past,
say that five times fast, will appear
on that screen, and
Pierce now will tell us
about Pierce then.
It's very "Inception."
Okay, here's the first Pierce.
(screen toggles)
(bell dings)
All right, here we go.
- Oh my God.
- First of all,
I wanna ride that. (laughs)
- Okay, so I'm finished at drama school,
three years of drama school.
I'm trained in the
method, a serious actor.
However, you have to make a living.
I found a commercials agent,
and you had to have
photographs doing silly things.
And that's one of them.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] That's not silly.
That looks fun.
- So, so goofy.
Yes, that was me trying
to get commercial work.
- Can I tell you my personal favorite part
is the fancy sweater look
that you just finished
at tennis club, and then your scooter.
You know, you don't
have a Porsche outside.
You have this scooter outside.
(both laugh)
It's great.
That builds character.
Here we go.
(screen toggles)
Okay, what's the next one?
(bell dings)
Oh, "Remington Steele."
- Oh, my dear, dear Stephanie.
(audience cheers)
Stephanie Zimbalist and I.
This was a turning point in my life.
It created a whole world for me.
It gave me the life and career
that I have-
- Was this your first series
here in America?
- This was my first series.
I came over here, wow, as I say, in 1982
on a wing and a prayer, my late wife,
and she, God bless her, said,
"We should go to America."
I said, "How the heck are
we gonna go to America?
"We just bought a house."
And we borrowed two
grand, hopped on a plane,
came over here to Los Angeles.
- Both dreamers
- And stayed in Hollywood.
I rented a car from Rent-A-Wreck.
- [Kelly] (laughs) I love it.
- It was a lime green Pacer.
- You should have brought
the scooter. (laughs)
- Should have brought it. (whistles)
- I'm just picturing James
Bond on the scooter. (laughs)
It's incredible.
My son's name is Remington.
I didn't even put it together
until obviously that's
like what you came to.
I was like, that's my son's name.
- Well, I went for the first interview,
and that was "Remington
Steele," and I did the job,
so there you have it.
- I think it was a hit.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
All right, let's see the next one.
(screen toggles)
(bell dings)
(Kelly murmurs)
Oh, there you go.
(audience cheers)
Everyone loved "Mrs. Doubtfire."
I don't know what a human on this planet
that doesn't love "Mrs. Doubtfire."
So it must have been something else
to work with Robin, right?
- It was such a blast,
so memorable.
I mean, if I never did anything else,
I made "Mrs. Doubtfire," and this job came
at a time where I was really worrying
about the mortgage payment, (laughs),
and they said, "You got a
job with Robin Williams."
And it was truly magnificent experience.
I remember the first
day up in San Francisco,
it was a gorgeous sunny
day, and they said,
"Well, welcome, and do
you wanna meet Robin?"
I said, "Yeah."
And he said, "He's in the makeup trailer."
So I went into the makeup trailer,
and he was sitting there
and he had a Hawaiian
shirt on and big hairy arms
and legs and cargo pants,
but Mrs. Doubtfire, his head.
- That's so creepy.
It's really weird.
"Oh, hello, Pierce.
"Oh, give us a kiss."
(Kelly laughs)
"Hey, buddy, nice to see you.
"How you doing?"
"Hey, oh, high five."
- Revert back. (laughs)
- So, and I really
never worked with Robin.
I worked with Mrs.
Doubtfire the whole time
because he was in makeup at
four o'clock in the morning.
I'd come in for my work, and-
- Oh, that's so funny.
- And so, I never saw Robin.
It was always Mrs. Doubtfire.
- It just must be cool as
an actor to be a part of.
I mean, God, you've been a
part of so many huge things,
but just something that
I feel like families,
that's just that film
was such a huge thing
in pop culture for families.
Like, it doesn't matter what age you were,
everybody loved that movie.
- No, it's a very healing film.
Very joyful film.
And it has lasted
the test of time.
- Yeah, classic, yeah.
- It is a classic, so to
be part of that, brilliant.
- Well, I'm moving on.
Here we go, next Pierce.
(screen toggles)
- Oh, this is like
"This Is Your Life."
(bell dings)
- I know, I remember that show, yeah.
(audience cheers)
"This Is Your Life" (indistinct).
Oh my God, I have to ask you about this.
I love "Mamma Mia!"
I have never seen a more stacked cast.
- It's truly stacked cast.
- That cast was
every person that came on
camera was like a legend.
Like it was an incredible
cast to be part of.
Were you nervous about singing or excited?
- Oh, I was nervous.
I was terrified.
I mean, I did-
- Really?
- Oh, I was-
- You did such a great job.
- Terrified, thank you for saying so.
I'd never sung in a movie before,
but this movie really was a game changer.
And it's easy to fall in love with Meryl.
It's easy to fall in love
with every member of the cast.
Yes, truly.
- And Colin.
I mean, everybody in that
movie is so great, yeah.
- It was criminal how much fun we had
because everyone brought their wives,
their girlfriends, the boyfriends.
- Oh, that's cool.
- So it became a family.
And we rehearsed for about five weeks.
Everyone got on extremely well together.
So maybe "Mamma Mia 3."
We're talking about it.
- Let's do it.
(audience cheers)
Let's do it.
Okay, last Pierce, here we go.
(screen toggles)
(bell dings)
Okay, wait, this is the new one.
- This is the new one.
This is "The Out-Laws"
with Adam DeVine there.
Ellen Barkin, and Nina Dobrev.
And this is coming out July 7th,
and it's a romp.
(audience cheers)
- So I love that it's
called "The Out-Laws."
So is it because you're in-laws,
but you might be, is it bank robbers?
- Well, it's a kind of
spinoff of "The In-Laws,"
which is an old movie,
but we're the out-laws.
And Adam DeVine, he's
a nerdy bank manager.
He's getting married to his lovely girl.
Her parents are coming in, Ellen and I,
and we've been in...
We supposedly have been in
the Amazon studying a tribe,
but really we're bank robbers.
- Possibly.
- We're bank robbers.
We come in to rob banks.
- That's incredible.
- It's a romp of a movie.
So much fun.
- Seems very witty.
- It's witty, it's fast, it's comedic.
It's a great ensemble, again, of actors
and such a wonderful time doing it, so...
- I like you in comedies,
and the "Eurovision" one too,
that was one of the last times we talked.
I loved "Eurovision."
- Oh, that was so silly.
- I mean, you actually
made me cry in that too.
You were funny, and you made me cry.
So well done.
Theaters worked out for you.
- That's good.
- But, no, I love you in comedies,
so I love that you're doing that.
All right, that was our game.
You're welcome, America.
(audience cheers)
- That's all, thank you.
- "The Out-Laws: is on Netflix in July,
and don't forget to check
out Pierce's art exhibition.
It's called "So Many Dreams."
He's incredible.
It starts Sunday, May 13th
at 434 North La Brea in Los Angeles.